May 2016 NASA's Terra satellite beams
back routine images of Rhode Island's
forests but something's very wrong you
have this huge area of green trees in
the middle of the forest and it looks
like they're brown patches that are
spreading out across the forest
satellite imagery reveals these deadly
patches appear to be spreading and fast
this is really eerie something's not
right here with this forest closer
analysis of the images
reveals millions of lifeless trees and
Confirmation this dead zone has been
created in just a matter of weeks
it's shocking and it's bare and dead and
barren total devastation what is going
on what's killing these trees
investigators examine the satellite
image for clues 30 miles from the
devastation lies what remains of a
notorious Cold War biological research
complex on Plum Island it's kind of like
a creepy movie research facility where
you don't really know what's happening
there the bio lab carried out top-secret
experiments and many locals are
convinced that the effects of these
experiments are not confined to the
island it has been linked to the
outbreak of Lyme disease bird flu a
number of contagions that are are quite
alarming and dangerous when suddenly you
have this massive die-off event of trees
just miles away from Plum Island it
certainly is impossible to resist
linking the two events
when investigators visit the scene they
are shocked by what they discover or to
be precise what they hear the forest is
alive with a strange sound a low-level
rasping echoes through the trees
it's the sound of mandibles
insect jaws billions upon billions of
insect jaws this is an army of literally
billions that are going through these
forests and eating tree after tree after
tree it's like a plague of biblical
proportions
investigators scour historical records
and discover it's a plague of voracious
larvae from a genetic experiment gone
horribly wrong